hey everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on very excited to be
talking about values based innovation we
have margarita cubes joining us on the
show hi margarita hi Ann how are you
thank you so much for coming on the
program really appreciate it thank you
very excited to have you on and also
that we had mark Nelson on the show yeah
gingka new on the show as well talking
about peace technology the peace
Innovation Lab for those who don't know
margaritas background
she's co-director of Stanford's peace
Innovation Lab and member of the
behavior design lab applying systematic
ways to shift human behavior for
business and societal outcomes and
you'll find all the links in a bio blow
to her website as well as the peace
innovation web sites and the LinkedIn
Twitter profiles we're gonna have had a
such a good time talking to you before
we started let's jump into things with
understanding more about why exactly
your heart beats for this ah you know my
heart beats for this because I have a
son and he's 19 and there's something
transformative that happens to someone
when you have a child
all of a sudden whatever you were doing
is there like it's it's a marker in your
life there's you know before child and
after child and when you're holding this
baby in your arms you think I would do
anything I would devote my life so this
child could have a happy thriving life
ahead of them and I think the the thing
that drives me is my son quite honestly
it's like how how do I take what I have
and direct it toward that outcome that
there's a healthy world for him to grow
up in and that I've had a good run it's
you know and for him when he's my age I
want him to have had a good life and so
I want to be able to tell him on you
know on my deathbed I did everything I
could
especially in this era where we have
these existential threats where it's one
of those rare times in history where you
have to do you have to step back and
think what am i doing and will it be of
consequence especially when the stakes
are so high that's why I do this yeah
like how you put it it's a big marker in
our lives when we continue propagating
on the cycle of life and we want to make
sure that the children of the next
generation have an an incredible quality
of life and they're able to adventure
into consciousness with a great amount
of of basic needs that are met for them
that they can become a stifle creativity
and they should find meaning in life all
this good type of stuff I love I love a
focus on that and helping catalyze
change in behavior to have a greater
degree of stewardship for Earth they're
just a better understanding of the
ultimate nature of reality why we're
even here is just a very important thing
that we're very passionate about that we
talk about along the program and it's
very difficult to make impact on
people's lives that lasts more than just
the moment and that's something that I'm
pumped to talk to you about as well how
did you figure out on your life journey
that this is what your heart was gonna
end up beating for if you had asked me
when I was 17 I did not know I did the
my life has been based on a poll rather
than a push the when I was growing up we
certainly we I'm part Yaqui some half
Native American and the oral histories
of my family and how not our only are we
survivors but were warriors so we were
one of the few native tribes that
weren't conquered in North America and
that's a very powerful origin story yeah
right to have to know that you have the
DNA of all your ancestors and they've
all were
they their lives were in in the hope of
someone like me and there's this saying
that I saw on the internet saying that
we are we are our ancestors wildest
dreams right and so you go like wow if I
am if I'm carrying the DNA of all the
generations behind me and there's
there's an interesting research about
how women how mothers carry have the
cells of their children inside them
mm-hmm and our children have our cells
inside them as well and so there's also
this chain that connects us yeah
to to all that is for me if you know all
my female ancestors right
that's pretty cosmic right and and so
they're going so sometimes I feel all
these native girls on my shoulder and
looking through my eyes and they're
going like wow we made it this far so
what are we gonna do now
right if we've come this far we must
have a purpose yeah we came here for a
reason and part of I think for everyone
their quest is to find out what they're
there why is why it why are they here
and for me is to continue to to be
present that all those people all those
Native peoples all those indigenous
people it's like I feel like a spy
you know like I'm in disguise you know I
have this skin on right and these the
whatever and the modern clothing and all
that but all my ancestors are along for
the ride that got like damn we finally
got in the room okay and with these
decision-makers and with these
influencers and so on and so part of my
responsibility is making sure that that
voice gets heard and gets represented
yeah I love that cosmic perspective you
go back to our parents and their parents
and their parents and just keep going
back we all come from the same source
first place and then on top of that then
there's this idea that you actually do
carry all of your lineage you carry your
lineage they're there in a sense
especially for someone that is coming
from a Native American background here
that you're at the table like you said
you're at the table you're working with
influencers on making drastic change now
that can hopefully catalyze a new era a
new world of maximizing our prosperity
so I love that cosmic perspective to it
okay this is I think pretty hard to to
understand because this is a this is a
little bit more of what sometimes we
would think of as as an abstract
moonshot that that we can somehow figure
out how to incentivize peace on our
planet there's actually a lot of value
that's in peace and people like
financial incentive so they really yeah
so teach us about that and about what
you guys are then figuring out how to do
at peace Innovation Lab sure I mean
passive peace is an abstract concept
right it's about as vague as you can get
along with many other things that are
very aspirational you see that in
corporate mission statements you see
that in people's personal statements or
even a society or religion they're very
aspirational you say well how do you
what is that meeting in the day-to-day
and so in our lab given our heritage
coming from Vijay Foggs than persuasive
technology lab we care about how people
behave toward each other and actually
that also speaks to my own life you know
in terms of discrimination racism sexism
or whatever I cannot control how what
people think of me
I don't have any influence over that and
so I do care how they treat me what
their behavior is and as long as their
behavior is fair I actually don't care
what they think and some ways and we're
in the positive peace business so when
we're talking about that we're talking
about pro-social behavior and so we
really unpack that like you know here we
are in the Bay Area
and we're going about our work and we go
to the grocery store or when we drive on
the roads and so on and so forth and
it's remarkable that 15 million people
get along as well as they do
if you thought I would have put fifteen
million people in a small space and you
got to navigate the day when you stop
and really reflect on your day it is
remarkably free of friction mm-hmm you
know we know how to interact with each
other we're not breaking out at
fistfights at the Starbucks you know we
take turns at at you know stop signs we
know how to queue up we do this we do
that neither all of that those tiny
instances those are behaviors of
positive peace you know and I think one
of the challenges that we have right now
in civil society given the polarization
is how do we continue to maintain that
as a really good habit to be kind to
each other to show respect to show
compassion to show empathy and you say
empathy let's do empathy and go wow that
sounds really abstract well what does
empathy mean in the moment what does
compassion mean in the moment it might
mean I was a day on the airplane flying
back from Amsterdam and I'm recovering
from a an infection and so the
antibiotics had me a little bit weak and
tired and I was trying to get my bag
into the overhead cuz I was single
traveler right and the the the steward
came up and said can I help you with
that and I go how did you know and he
just you it was effortless it was a tiny
act of kindness right and he's going
like okay there's a small woman
struggling with this bag trying to get
it up over her head and let me just take
care of that in that moment
mm-hmm and so that's what we mean in
terms of behavior right and so how do we
cultivate that behavior how do we
reinforce that in college in corporate
parlance that's creating a great
customer experience right this kind of
immediately is jumping me into like you
said there's 15 million people in this
densely packed metropolis area and the
idea that they can function harmoniously
together as a society within the fabric
that we exist in is in itself already
miraculous and there are these tiny
little instances of peace that are being
incentivized because when everyone
agrees to a specific modality of
existing on the money is this the
transit systems are this way and you
agree on these things
at least until better things are created
that can then archive the old ones that
then it makes it so that you can have a
more frictionless society that gets fat
that gets places faster that can create
more effectively that can provide basic
needs better but then you know as you're
giving me this example with the steward
the flight attendant there's this to me
like that it's almost like who were
their parents because their parents must
have had somewhat of of a pretty serious
influence on the child's upbringing
where the child sees someone that needs
assistance with their bag or needs
assistance crossing the street or
whatever it is and that they go and
approach them and help them right and
that there this whole idea of like a
social credit system or some sort of an
immediate reward feedback loop that
happens for positive behavior positive
pro-social behavior which is what we had
as a definition on that show with you
mark I which we really like positive
pro-social behavior just sounds like why
wouldn't we want to have that everywhere
right and then like what's this idea of
well what if I had an immediate feedback
loop or I see you I help
you in some way and then maybe I gain a
couple like social credit points maybe
but even even more it doesn't have to be
as complicated as I it's um you know and
and and I when I work with corporate
executives Nate was doing this the other
week I said like okay here's an example
you know I want you to break up into
groups and there are two coffee shops
and they're right next to each other
coffee shop and coffee shop be why do
you prefer one over the other and write
down all the reasons and then
collectively say okay why do you do like
well you know I go because you know it's
it's beans it's hot water
they got tables they got chairs they got
a counter all these things are
commodities this is very utilitarian
right so they're the same they're the
same so why do you prefer one over the
other and we started to talk about
aesthetics we started to talk about
feelings we taught it to start talking
about the sublime right and that is what
makes something special that is what
makes a relationship or an experience
special you know if you back in the day
when Virgin Airlines was operating and
then you had United and United of course
was in the headlines for how they
treated their passengers and dragging
them off and so on and and people say
well I'm gonna hire highly regulated
industry it's very hard for me to
innovate and I go look
but United and and virgin are in a
highly regulated industry you know they
got planes the planes got to be operate
this way they don't have any control
over the airports they don't have any
control over when they take off and land
there's a lot that is dictated but it's
the stuff that isn't dictated that makes
a difference in the experience mm right
and it's those intentional choices and
the point of view that they have about
the customer how they regard them what
they're trying to do and when Branson
talked about designing virgin he says I
come from entertainment I nightclubs and
music and so to me there are guests and
so this is basically a flying nightclub
in the sky I got pink and blue lights
and you know get cocktails on demand and
a great music and it's a great
atmosphere because that's what I want
that's the experience I want to recreate
and
then you happens to be a very funky club
venue happens to be on a plane
United looks at people as if they're
moving Freight you're just an object
that's that's to be moved from a point A
to point B at that time and if it's
overbooked well I have too many boxes
let me let me just remove a box right
hence the the Dennis who lost his teeth
and so on and so forth but if you and I
were to brainstorm and say how can we
great a really great great customer
experience and what are we do in the
case when the plane is overbooked I bet
you are hundred top ideas would not
include dragging that guy off the plane
and breaking his teeth who would do that
and yet it happens right and so if you
step back and say what are my values and
what is what is the feeling that I want
my customer to have and this comes from
video games actually for my game
designer I'm my my thoughts are very
much influenced by Chris Bennett it's
like game designers think about what is
it that while I want the player to feel
emotionally what do I want them to feel
physiologically are they you know is are
they excited or they shaking adrenaline
are they frustrated the confuse or the
elated and then what are the game
mechanics and dynamics that I'm putting
into play in order to elicit that
emotion in order to elicit that
physiology so in this sense this would
be like the Stewart or flight attendant
noticing that maybe your emotional
levels are in some sort of a state that
are in need of physical assistance and
they come over and they because they're
they're maybe I'm more sensitive they're
aware of your emotional state they come
over and assist you physically with with
with the lifting your luggage into the
into the compartment and then they see
your emotional relief right they see you
happier right who you are like I think I
think someone noticed and helped me and
I have more relief I was feeling sick as
well and so then you know the flight
attendant then gets also there like I
was able to help someone I feel great as
well exactly and that's a different kind
of currency so game designers talk about
different currency
when they're when they're putting
together games are doing that the
economics and a lot of games aren't they
don't start with the art and what the
characters look like they start with a
spreadsheet and they figure out what the
different currencies are and so in
society we also have different
currencies but we tend to focus only on
the dollar but there are emotional
currencies reputational currencies
social status currencies that people are
willing to trade in right and so in that
moment with the flight attendant he had
the opportunity to if I was thinking as
a game design it's like oh here's an
opportunity for me to delight her mm-hmm
you know I'm gonna give her delight and
I'm going to relieve her anxiety yes so
it's both right yes and also themselves
feeling like they get a range exactly
and they give a boost out of that as
well and we know from the psychology
research that that happens right and so
so then it's not just about dollars but
it's about other other rewards that are
happening as well I like the view of
this from the perspective of a game
designer I think that's so crucial
because we on the show talk frequently
about you know what is this big game
that we're all embedded in what a source
what is creation why are we on a rock
orbiting star and we birth into these
bodies and we have these extend evers
into consciousness and one of the ways
that we frequently address this is from
the perspective of a designer like a
universe designer like why is it
designed this specific way and when you
think about that more deeply you kind of
get into all of this also it is slightly
more esoteric and like metaphysical but
it also sight in spiritual but at the
same time it is this like a deeply
emotional practical another being that
has consciousness is in need of some
sort of assistance and I can have a
deeper amount of emotional intelligence
and just and just presence in general
with another person that has
consciousness in assisting them with
this process and that again is not
necessarily immediately increasing my my
social score in the world but it has not
unlike a fit not on like an actual
digital ledger a physical score yet
but it is some sort of an interpersonal
dynamics that like we said there's a
psychological boost here there's a
anxiety decrease for you and an
emotional boost for you I mean so so
let's think as like game designers right
so so we have the mechanic in the
dynamic the mechanic is the suitcase the
dynamic is lifting it up right so that's
the behavior the action he could have
done it and and and the the
physiological and emotional outcome
could have been shame embarrassment
humiliation anger you know on my part
depending upon his town right it's so
it's not just the fact of I'm gonna take
the bag in and put it up it's it's how
you do it and the intention behind it
like the idea of it being potentially
like ah another customer that needs help
with this problem right or he just
drinks it out of my hand or he versus
all let me let me help
exactly exactly and so that is the
difference that little Delta is the
difference because both acts are
utilitarian you know so here we ha the
design problem is you need to help you
know the person needs to get their their
bag in the overhead yeah so interesting
so it both acts being a utilitarian and
help it chemically do this exactly the
same but they have a different emotional
physiological outcome and so if he say
he did it in a way that upset me and I'm
taking this antibiotic which makes me
very tired and vulnerable anyway then
that would have set off as mark would
say this whole neurochemical stream in
my body that would have affected me in a
much deeper level in my body mm-hmm
right versus in this case you actually
went up well I absolutely went up I felt
relief I felt safe I felt like if I
asked him to do something for me it
would be okay I wouldn't be embarrassed
mm-hmm right let me let me see if then
so then examples like this for you guys
are
you get to analyze examples these
positive pro-social behaviors then you
get to also work with corporations to
you you gave this example with like
United versus Virgin Airlines there's so
many other examples with corporations as
well as just what are these positive
pro-social behaviors and you give these
really good examples and you try and
catalyze them more of more awareness
with what we just described exactly you
can design this you can be intentional
and you know translating this to a
language that corporates that it
resonates with this is about how to do
you know here's the thing
weird in day and age where so many
products are just commodities
everything comes manufactured out of
China so you got this and you got that
and they're the same so why would
someone choose you over somebody else
intent usually value content is gonna be
because of how you make them feel
interesting so certain values are about
how you make them feel right and it has
to resonate with what they care about
because otherwise it's just molded
plastic versus molded plastic it's an
app versus an app you know even in
financial services it's Bank a versus
Bank B well I mean the the
differentiation with a lot of products
and services in the world is marginal
mmm it really is and so if you want to
have a competitive advantage it's all
about how you treat people
mm-hm and and to the extent that you can
be kind you're warmer more compassionate
more empathetic mmm-hmm
that is a net positive in the world
because then that person goes about
their day and they feel better and that
that emotion is contagious and what's
interesting about working with
corporates is that they have resources
and they have pain points they're trying
to be more profitable they're trying to
find an edge and so they come to us and
say we want you know digital
transformation or we need to be more
innovative
and I always say why is it because it's
the fad because everyone else is and if
you do that how will you how will it be
any different than what you have right
now and for your customer they're not
thinking so like whoa you know what I'm
really looking forward is you know going
to X Y Z's corporate website they don't
think that they're worth thinking about
my their personal needs their their
goals their aspirations where they want
to go in the world and looking you know
and in in that moment where they go oh I
need I need a tool I need something to
help me get there right mm-hmm
yeah people aren't like product centric
they're they're personal goal centric
their family centric their relational
centric my mom is sick I need X mm-hmm
right that's what drives a lot of human
behavior so you need to understand that
mm-hmm okay
so we were talking before we started we
started endeavoring into this idea of
this like big wide behind everything
that we do and when it's when it's very
clear this idea of like a big why well
okay well I it's not just some I want to
make the world better but it's a very
clear like I'm making the world better
in this specific way because of this
specific value or belief that I have and
then it becomes more clear okay and then
the examples of when we were talking we
kind of made it clear that well if
you're gonna build tech and everyone
uses these examples but it's just that
like you really can build tech with more
values based innovation and intention
and emotional awareness where it's
driven more in the direction of of
raising the basic needs for people
around the world and not having those
lips of malevolence that occur with
technology because we don't have the
ethicists or the Philosopher's of the
moral scientists that are embedded with
computer scientists and chemists and
biology engineers like we just need a
a little bit more foresight when it
comes to putting together the biggest
corporations around the world and the
biggest governments around the world and
how they interplay with each other and
so this idea of having like a big a big
why well why should there be why should
there be some sort of a peace incentive
or peace innovative inclusive stake
holding system that occurs when when I
as a computer scientist and bringing
some sort of value to the world and all
of a sudden I tie in an ethicist along
the way what does that do well it
actually has a value that's attached to
it which is that the the 50 or a hundred
thousand dollars a year that I pay for
an ethicist to come and work with a team
of computer scientists actually has
effects of multiple millions of dollars
down the line of malevolence that is
actually that just never happens never
happens it's interesting there was a New
York Times story on the the top AI guy
at Facebook and his career and how
brilliant he was and so on and so forth
and how his job day-to-day is figuring
out developing AI to root out a really
malicious content and it is you know
child pornography and terrorism and
people beheading each other and but the
worst of the worst right and I felt so
sorry for him because here was someone
who was talented who said I'm going to
study computer science and AI because I
want to make the world a better place in
some in some manner and he spent his day
and his team's day in the thankless task
I sort of like cleaning out the Aegean
stables every day mmm and there's just
more crap and it was just more crap and
they can't keep up with it what is the
root cause right and because what they
had done was they had opened up this
Pandora's box and and and there was just
no putting it back and so his career has
been reduced to that
it was it was sad it was poignant
because it's like how depressed he must
be because every day he has to go in and
and and you know he's got a teaspoon
know to try to clean out you know thing
and at the end of the day because I
didn't even make a dent and when I come
back there's gonna be 10 times more what
is the root cause of of us propagating
terrorism videos or beheading videos and
there's something that is just when were
children are born into the world they
don't get that recognition that this is
a divine place for them to have had the
opportunity to pursue a conscious
endeavor and when we're still the
globally not recognizing that this is a
divine place that we can all have great
abundance and love and prosperity on
then we're gonna run into issues like
this we have we have a an example that
that you gave me earlier that I thought
was really interesting when you when you
dive into the depths of forced migration
and of climate change and you find some
very crazy things that you were teaching
me about and your solution to it was
really cool the you know the peace and
Conflict and climate change are
intertwined when we look at the
challenges of this century it's going to
be food water energy security and and
that's a constant in terms of humanity
but it's more acute now because of
climate it's changing the boundary
conditions it's changing the the context
in which people operate in so when you
look at the mass migrations that we've
seen from Central America people don't
leave their home and - unless it's the
it's the decision of last resort in
Syria many researchers looked at the
root cause of the Civil War and said it
was due to climate change
and what syndrome and it was about the
cost of bread now mind you bread is the
food of last resort when we think about
what we eat
there are commodities trading that's
done on grains soy corn wheat because
you can store that and it has a very
very long shelf life right and so people
can eat bread for a long time the thing
that doesn't store indefinitely is
produce mm-hmm
fruit vegetables spices and so if you're
in a region we don't have a way to
detect when there's scarcity yeah
there's some drop-off of all of us in
the marketplace there's a marked
reduction in fresh fruit locally grown
fresh fruit and vegetables right and so
that's actually and so there's no
there's nothing that there's no red
light that goes off on anyone's desk
that says oh we need to look at that
because if this continues then the next
thing when once that food source has
been eliminated all you really have is
bread yeah and if the bread prices go up
is because and people are rioting over
the cost of bread it's because they
don't have anything else to eat and we
don't have a good way to detect that but
imagine if we did then we could get
ahead of these problems because by the
time that people have to migrate then it
becomes a political issue and certainly
we saw that in Germany a few years ago
as Syrians were migrating into Germany
and everyone's going like well I'll take
a few but I'm not - cannot going to take
many and and then you have refugees and
the refugee camps you think they're not
going to be around for long they'll be
around for 20 years these people who are
stateless who were jobless who can't get
integrated into the local economy
because people don't want that flood of
cheap labor rights as a protectionism
behavior like okay we're going to keep
them here and hopefully they'll go away
they'll go back we're just gonna have
more and more of that so you know how do
we if we know that that's going to be an
issue then the
going okay you got to go wayne gretzky
where's the pup gonna be what do we need
to put in place so we can detect that
and address it when the problem is small
and relatively inexpensive both
economically and politically I love this
scarcity meter or scarcity radar or just
a prediction capability through pattern
analysis of of observing less less
produce being made more people
purchasing bread more scarcities being
developed well there's likely some sort
of issue that's happening in that area
and given the continuation of that issue
you can expect to have more symptoms
arise and so having foresight with the
way that we are able to leverage
artificial intelligence and computer
science pattern recognition to do things
like prevent a forced mass migrations
and prevent other sorts of like children
having trauma growing up because of
things like that and so that has that
saves again millions in billions of
dollars when you look at life
trajectories and life outcomes and the
need for for for like needing to use
pharmaceuticals versus being able to
like provide creative value to society
this is a this is a very massive thing
and but one of the big things that I
think a lot of the time we we you know
we talked about in our conversation and
people like to know is like okay well
what do you do about something that is
as drastic as having a you know yeah you
can put in some sort of a pattern
recognition system for that type of
stuff but there's some sort of other
deeper rooted behavior change that has
to happen and how do you make it last
longer than an incremental piece of
content that somebody absorbs and then
sure I mean so there are a couple of
different ways that you can have lasting
behavior change and the most powerful
one is changing the context okay if you
change the environment you change the
context you change people's behavior
so people say like you know people never
change or it's so hard for me to change
my habits and I go go travel for a month
if you go travel for a month all your
old habits are broken because you're not
waking up in your same old bed you don't
have your same old routine I'm gonna go
to the bathroom and walk over the
kitchen make myself a cup of coffee
settle that all of that gets blown up
right all of a sudden you are thinking
about where am I gonna eat what am I
gonna do what is it and everything
changes right and then you come up with
a new routine for travel or you come up
with a new routine for exercise while
you're traveling or whatever right and
so when the environment changes you
change yes and so guess what planet
we're all in for a lot of change because
our context is changing and so the
question is how do we change and adapt
in a way that is constructive and
productive and pro-social and how do we
do it in a way where we can be good to
each other maybe where it's incentivize
where it's incentivize and part of the
incentive is you know that there's
policy and law and legislation because
that basically provides the rules of the
game so it's interesting so and having
spent enough time in Europe you go why
you know kisses Europe versus us
whatever and I'm going like wow and in
Europe they have a lot of labor
protection mm-hmm okay so you can't work
80 hours a week in the Nordics is just
not allowed
unlike Silicon Valley so that means okay
they don't create Silicon Valley kind of
craziness on the other hand there's no
labor exploitation right because that's
the rule of the game it's just not even
on the table so it's not like one
company could say well I'm going to you
know I would love to have my people only
work 32 hours a week but my competitor
hasn't worked 60 hours a week so I have
to do that as well this law level sets
everyone and says sorry no one can get
an unfair advantage by harming people
this way and harming people in terms of
taking away from their relationships or
families all the other things that they
need to do in civil society we've
contained it yes we want your labor but
we want it like this and the wages are
going to be like that mm-hmm
and so as a consequence because of the
rules of that game you
see massive homelessness in Europe the
way you do here right and here we're
trying to solve homelessness but the
rules of the game are such that in a
winner-take-all you will get
homelessness there they've said that we
don't even want that as an outcome so as
we design this game we just take that
option off the table the conditions that
would allow for that we we pulled that
card that rule we scratched it out just
you know you can't do that mmm so that's
what in terms of you know the
intentionality of how you design a
society right and that's something that
engineers don't do because we don't
study that we don't do we don't study
what is it to have a good life or what
is it to have a just society we spend
four years working on problem sets
mm-hmm it's the humanities majors who
sit there who think who read who write
who really ponder these issues and we
actually I don't think we have enough
humanities people in positions of
leadership in Silicon Valley because
they would bring that necessary
perspective and say I want you to
innovate but I want you to do in the
service of creating a just society and
this is what it looks like
can you innovate for that and as an
engineer I just need to know what my
what my conditions are you say this is
the spec it needs to do this this and
this and it has to call us this much and
this material and got it it's just you
add it to the design spec so this is
where you know if you can if we can
bring these values at the point of
design then it's baked in yeah
oh man it's like if you see all of the
potential trajectories that exist in
terms of a civilizations outcome or even
at a smaller level the the not the
nation's outcome you can do things like
you can see the ones those little
bifurcating moments that send the
civilization or the nation into worse
outcomes and you can prevent youn take
preventive measures that ensure that
there are the symptom of homelessness
does not occur the symptom of suicide
does not occur the symptom of a poor
stake holding inclusive stake holding
does not occur because when there is no
inclusive stake holding you get self
dealing habits of physicians or of
teachers or if corporations that deal to
themselves rather than to the people
that they actually serve with their
employees with their customers with
society at large the communities that
they're in this this this is so so so
important in it also it also kind of
makes me think about like you know when
you're talking about and this is a the
piece innovation has a you guys this is
like a collaborative project in the
Netherlands that you guys we have an
institute in the Netherlands Institute
in the Netherlands and you were giving
this example where you're talking about
about you know Europe taking some sort
of measures that are different than the
US is and we're talking about making
long-term behavior change well you talk
to me about this before we started but
if you do on your on your transit
service if you see the option for if you
walk it's gonna take this long for your
bike you'll take this long if you take a
Carl take this long if you it said your
bus will take this long but next to that
is the price ban it's just the price
shows up right but that third one is now
the carbon footprint right and then it
becomes embedded in everything you see
all the oh absolutely once when it was
that the app is called transer tra and
er is in Europe and and Mark had
downloaded it last week and he goes oh
margarita look at this and he goes look
it tells you what the cost is if you
just drive yourself because normally
when you get these transit apps you're
saying I'm trying to get from point A to
point B it's like Google Maps right and
it says you know you know you are you to
drive is it gonna use transit are you
gonna walk or you know bike and it gives
you the times and so most people are
looking the the metric that matters is
time right and then money right and so
then and then when you're looking at
public transit of course they're telling
you what the cost is so that way you
know yes and so in this one it told you
the time and and the route and you know
you got to get on you know the sixteen
tram and then you transfer and blah blah
blah and and the cost boom boom boom but
then it also but if you choose not to do
any of this and you just drive yourself
it was a good difference between 11
euros and 35 euros mm-hm and the 35
euros were if you drove yourself now how
many of us are conscious of how much it
costs us to drive 10 miles we think it's
free I think that there isn't any cost
because we already own the car you know
we have forgotten that cost and so I so
I did some screenshots and I got okay so
it's 35 dollars so I Drive myself and
then I click to see more and then it
tells me what my carbon footprint is
when I Drive and that was interesting
because then I said oh the metric that
matters is carbon footprint because if
we don't solve this in the next 10 years
it doesn't matter what the price was hmm
it won't matter all the money in the
world is not going to help you if the
planet is ruined and so it would be
interesting if I could wave a magic wand
I would have a carbon footprint call
them on every receipt so and then all of
a sudden you would start thinking like
wait a minute so every item every I
don't believe buying a computer yeah
like buying a pillow
right I mean every eye every item tell
me what the carbon footprint is because
then you would be going like oh wait
what cuz then I'm making a different
comparison you're also pushing people to
understand the manufacturing processes
of the items absolutely purchase which
actually decreases ignorance and
increases awareness in general so so if
you wanted to move people away so we're
in the surveillance economy there's this
book about surveillance capitalism
you know we've moved from you know VHS
to DVD to streaming service because it's
so convenient isn't that flex so great
because it's so convenient if someone
told me what the carbon footprint was on
Netflix maintaining server farms all
around the world so I can just stream
you know the good place at any time I
wanted versus me getting the DVD from
the library I'm good like oh wait a
minute do I actually need my router on
24/7 nine hours of which my people are
asleep just so I could have the
convenience of in ten seconds being able
to download an episode of the good place
versus you know here's a DVD player when
you want it you plug it in you put the
DVD in you play your movie and you take
it out voila I mean what you know I
would be interested to see a comparison
of that when I was in the doctor's
office on Monday you know they're taking
my temperature they're taking my blood
pressure and I had that again that
carbon footprint moment where I'm going
Wow forty years ago the nurse would have
come in with a mercury thermometer she
would have stuck it under my tongue
gotten the measurement off written it
down she would have gotten the the blood
pressure pump
you know manually pumped it up looked at
the dial got it the carbon footprint for
those two items is zero in up and using
them in operation right we're not
excluding manufacturer but once you have
it to do it there's no carbon footprint
and now they have these fancy machines
to get the same two numbers
yeah there's there's there's definitely
some nuance with yeah with manufacturing
that leads up to the product but also on
the accuracy of the readouts of the data
points but in general catalyzing more
people through something as simple as
adding the carbon footprint number on
their transit app I think is a really
easy one that does that long term
awareness behavior change that we were
talking about and also just the idea of
when you look at everything at a store
that it always has a carbon footprint
attached to it maybe it even has to have
a quick little like paragraph or like a
quick little 20-second video about how
it was manufactured as well so that way
you know about what resources were used
what was the you know the Bill of
Materials the supply chain of where it
actually came from where it was
assembled all this type of
self-ownership
because I mean if we're if we're talking
carbon footprints of things that we buy
I mean things have to be transitive
quite a lot quite a distance to get to
us and barges our 90% of all world trade
happens by barge by sea and then you
have the automotive the trucking that
happens to move it from place to place
as well you know there's a lot of really
interesting solutions with with things
like nuclear fusion
we just need again we need again this is
a big thing like if you want energy
that's free close to as free as possible
or completely free or zero emission you
really need the teams of the best
scientists in the world and the best
funding in the world that pushes us
towards innovating towards that that
free forever sustainable like nuclear
fusion technology otherwise you're gonna
we're gonna get stuck again with with
not identifying root issues energy was
one water was one food was one these are
very root issues basic needs and I mean
they're not gonna go away so let's fast
forward 10 years yes you know people are
still gonna be raising children they
still need to get food on the table they
still need to take care of their sick
mother-in-law all the stuff of the human
condition continues I mean during the
depths of World War
two people still needed to do all that
during I assure you during the Black
Plague in the Middle Ages people still
needed to do all that and the conditions
were harsh they were wicked but they
said ok and that the how of how I get
the food on the table of the how of how
I take care of family members of how of
how I do employment that changes right
and so for innovators the opportunity is
you know this is a new design constraint
this is a new design opportunity that
that inflection point because we need to
reinvent re-engineer all of the stuff
from the ground up and this is what
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley do
really well so this is the opportunity
where we can use our abilities to
disintermediate but do it in a very
intentional positive way as opposed to
I'm gonna disintermediate it and just
you know I just totally destroyed that
industry and I made myself a gazillion
dollars and say like that industry is
dead anyway there are a lot of
industries that are gonna that are full
of stranded assets because they're the
carbon footprint is just going to be too
expensive you just can't continue so at
some point someone's gonna call uncle
and say stop we just came over you guys
are done but that doesn't mean the need
that that company or that sector was
filling has gone away and so innovators
didn't need to say ok how do I do this
in a way where I minimize a carbon
footprint how do I do this in a way that
maximizes people's ability to be good to
each other because that's that's the way
we're all going to survive and thrive
and a lot of this comes from also what
we were talking about before hand which
is this process of teaching critical
thinking and teaching nuanced teaching
emotional intelligence and you gave this
really good example of something that
actually corporations would be very
interested in funding which is teaching
their employees about fishing techniques
and this is pH fishing and that's when
you have some
of a malevolent incoming threat that
happens that is hidden in some way it's
obfuscated that it is a threat and that
people so said that are susceptible to
the sceptic sort of susceptible to not
having vigilance with that with that
style of incoming threat fall for it
something like if you see paypal.com
sending you an email that's good it's
like support at PayPal calm but if it's
you know support are you at
you know PayPal are you calm or whatever
it could be coming from a Russian
phishing scam or from someone in the
u.s. trying to cast this phishing scam
to Russia or somewhere else in the world
as well these things happen a lot where
it's like please submit your password to
your account is under some sort of issue
but to get people practicing their
impressions getting their employees
practicing but also getting people
around the world practicing this like
little kindergarten task of like you
know be vigilant with what the email
addresses that you're getting with what
how it's structured what they're asking
you for and this is just like what we do
and we see is a new source that you want
to see what the sources exactly we did a
case study on that with a cyber security
company and when I was talking to David
know who was the behavior designer who
was working on this said I go to you
where do you see there's a piece tech
angle in this and I said absolutely I
mean as you said you know globally
people are losing their ability to
discern fact from fiction but if we said
well how are we going to address us
address that as a society the United
States that feels big abstract don't
even know where to start
who's gonna pay for it how would you do
that I mean how do you attack t'k Lee
how do you do this in any kind of
practical way but a corporation on the
other hand has a felt pain point because
they can calculate how much employee
time is lost in dealing with all this
fishing what the vulnerabilities are to
the enterprise
if an employee accidentally clicks on a
link that brings in some sort of
malevolent software into the
organization they can compute hard costs
yeah
- those behaviors of not having critical
thinking and in which case they go oh
okay
this is what it's costing me so I'm
willing to pay this much to fix it yep
right so they actually are corporations
are incentivized to address this problem
and so saying to david ago if we could
do this so that it is a building block
and you can take an employee and say get
them to be discerning enough to
understand that fact from fiction and
email then the next step is how did the
discern fact from fiction on sources of
information they read about on the
Internet
yep because in the inner what does it
mean to a company to CEO he or she has
their people working and doing you know
doing product research and if they can't
tell the difference between the
information that's valid and that's not
valid then the company might go down a
path erroneously because it got bad
information yeah right so so it's
actually hits their bottom line but then
once those people are trained you know
once they leave their office and go home
it's not like those skills went away
mm-hmm you know whatever they're reading
on the internet all of a sudden they
have a new lens they have this
capability of saying wait a minute you
know what I learned at work is if it has
these attributes it's probably phony I'm
reading this personally this is probably
wrong yeah I'm such a big fan of this
like kindergarten class that we all take
on on phishing that that increases our
our critical thinking and then there's
like first grade and second grade
classes that we can take that make us
better at being able to you know we do
it all the time with we don't typically
just go to one source for information or
we don't go to one source when we buy
something we go and shop meaning we look
at three or four different companies and
prices and similarly when we look for
knowledge we don't just go and look at
one specific source we're looking at
multiple sources and try to look at
those so
to me also thinking about how like the
style of critical thinking for children
and for adults can really catalyze the
again like a deeper behavioral change
towards positive pro-social long term
behavior and I love that in corporations
will front the bill because they see
that it the fright for them it's
multiple millions of dollars of cost if
they don't do this for they're right
there there's a real real bottom line
here
colleague of mine once told me said
recently you know a confused mind does
nothing and if you look at the strategy
the psychological strategy behind all
these disinformation campaigns from
Russia it's a very it's a really elegant
hack in terms of warfare because they
don't find need to fire a single shot
all they need to do is confuse Americans
so they do nothing because we don't know
what's real and what's not and because
we don't we can't move forward we can't
we can't act with confidence and and so
it's a it's as if they had transmitted a
nerve drug digitally cybernetically to
all of us so we're paralyzed and all we
can do is dispute you know what's real
and what isn't
man yeah when you put it into like yeah
this like cybernetic nerve drug I think
that's a very you know interesting and
novel way to put it is how can you also
potentially do a cybernetic a positive
pro-social that drug or behavior change
yeah cuz vaccine yeah you know what what
would you know what would that that be I
mean we have another interesting example
that you gave earlier to before we
started about the fair game Alliance
which I thought was really interesting
so you can take the companies that are
typically trying to you know hold on to
the players the players that are playing
their games and harassment and bullying
are major issues that caused players to
leave playing games and so they're not
sharing best practices in 60 or so these
companies sharing best practices so like
you know what would these best practices
be for society at large
catalyzed more positive pro-social pee
yeah and again for the business models
for these video game companies they're
not advertising driven right so it the
you know it's it you its
subscription-based it might be a loot
box and so on but its add-on so you go
in and I'm gonna I'm gonna buy stuff for
my avatar I'm gonna buy a costume I'm
gonna buy weapons I'm going to buy this
I'm gonna buy that the only way there
could be a buying opportunities if I'm
actually on the platform playing right
and so for because of that business
model these video game companies are
then majorly incentivized to keep those
players happy and it needs to be a
pleasant enough environment that they
hang around and play right unlike
Twitter and Facebook where their
business model is based on ads or
YouTube so they do the the the
underlying behavior of the people who
participate on the platform doesn't
matter to their bottom line as long as
they're selling ads so there's no
incentive for them except for one of
common decency but that's only when it
suits them to do something to change and
also the scale of their problem is is
quite large do you have with what with
what you and your team are are seeing of
a massive value add again like there's
there's a value deep economic value in
people learning positive pro-social
behavior and corporations funding the
employees to train to be trained in
these types of behaviors because it just
catalyzes more financial reward for
themselves and also just to catalyzes
more harmony between humans when we can
incentivize and do you guys have you
know we've listed so many examples but
I'm I'm really really really curious
about like on it just on there like a
global level about you know yeah like a
kindergarden fishing course that I can
go and take or that I can like now start
seeing the the carbon footprint for my
transit right or
the items that I'm buying like are these
the these are like the most cutting-edge
ideas for for a positive pro-social
behavior and like how can other people
you know partake in incentivizing this
positive pro-social behavior as well so
we're working with one one bank in
Europe where the CEO has stated what
their aspirations are to be as a bank in
terms of sustainability and different
sustainable development goals that have
been put forth for the EU and in terms
of of gender environment you know
fairness and so on and so we've been
working with them and saying okay so how
many of you are aware that you know your
CEO and this other countries put this
out there go oh we didn't know that to
go okay so how are you gonna
operationalize that because otherwise
it's just rhetoric it's right and a lot
of values are put in the box of CSR
which is about this big right and
especially with these companies we've
talked to they one of their pain points
is recruiting how did they get talent in
yeah how do you get Millennials in the
next generation to come in there are
very values based yes and they you know
Greta Sundberg and so they want to work
with the company that's actually gonna
have a positive impact but again
positive impact is as abstract and
social impact is as abstract as peace so
we're always talking about how do you
get this grounded into practical
everyday behaviors what does it you know
how will I know it how will I recognize
it when I see it and so we've been
working with them to think okay if we're
talking about you know more female
leadership we got to put numbers on it
what do you mean when you say that yeah
you know what do you mean when you say
sustainability give me a number
and once you start putting numbers
around them then people can start
rallying around that and I think that's
only going to increase because you
either are going to adapt to what the
world is going to look like in 10 years
or you're going to be out of the game
you'll be forced out of the game because
of regulators
or you'll be forced out of the game by
consumers because they will have chosen
that aspirational startup that just
disintermediated your industry yeah good
so you you actually don't have a choice
if you want to survive you've got to
change
you've got to incorporate this into your
products and services and not just the
PR opportunity that your CSR gives yeah
yeah a deeper embedding of the big
picture of something like the steamboat
developing goals into our into our to
the essence of ourselves on a and into
the projects that we build on an actual
tangible numerical behavior changing
alright and in order to for that to
happen it can't happen by engineering
centric or engineering exclusive teams
alone yeah this is where you need to get
people from other disciplines or to come
into those product development teams
yeah and to be able to say okay I come
from human rights
what would this supply chain software
look like if we made it impossible for
our vendors to commit human rights
violations yes I mean and people go like
what and I go look you know so when you
do your taxes Alan do you use something
like TurboTax
I don't okay yeah a lot of people do
right they use the TurboTax with some
software to file their taxes yes yeah
TurboTax is designed so that it's
foolproof
you will never violate any IRS laws when
you use their software to file your
taxes and don't make sure that you're
always inside that you know you're
you're good Yeah right because they know
the rules they know the law they've put
it into software code yes right and so
for me behaviorally it's easy for me to
file a good tax return right because I
just I just do it and I can't I I'm not
gonna get out of bounds right
child's born to the world if their world
is codified in a way where they can't
make any malevolent behavior so I mean
we're talking about something easier
aspirational and we're never gonna get a
hundred percent but we know that in the
absence of that aspiration these
technologies can and have been
weaponized mmm-hmm in absence yeah in
absence like people will find loopholes
too right and so part of it is being
mindful in saying ok within the within
the letter of the law people can't use
our software to violate the law in in
this thing that we're doing that would
be an interesting they're gonna be all
sorts of unintended consequences with
that scenario as well but how do we
instrument it so we can monitor that the
good that's being created yeah far
outweighs the bad because right now a
lot of software has there's some good
being created but the far far outweighs
the good mm-hmm
yeah this seems to continuously come
back to having a first principles
mentality around the things that we
build into the world and having them be
decreasing the potential for malevolence
and increasing the potential repository
behavior and that definitely requires
humanities and that requires ethicists
and philosophers embedded into engineers
of all sorts not just computer science
engineers but just engineering of all
sorts designing of all sorts so and
having some sort of a closed-loop
immediate system for an inclusive state
holding plus positive pro-social
behavior fabric that are pieced together
so I may be immediately getting that
that emotional boost when I'm helping
someone they get emotional boost and you
can both feel that but maybe there's
also some sort of another added layer of
like a digital ledger where you're
getting some sort of token who knows
this is uh this is all massive part of
our future and I'm very interested in
what you guys are doing I think
of us being able to help be a catalyst
first spreading what pieced innovation
is doing around the world
I'm is something that we care a lot
about and and hopefully we can continue
I'm featuring you guys as you continue
making new like little combinatorics of
piece innovation and releasing them into
the world and we can continue
highlighting them to people and
hopefully incentivizing or or catalyzing
their creative endeavoring into also
creating piece innovation style
technologies I'm a huge huge fan you
just do very work yeah thank you I want
to ask you about your relationship to
source or to all that is or to God or to
whatever you want to call it like what
is your relationship to the reason why
you're here and the reason why we're all
here
why am I here I am here as I said in the
beginning
to carry forward the values and memories
of my ancestors so my mother's from
Mexico and and you know I cannot
identify as Mexican mexican-american and
there is this saying that you're never
dead as long as people remember your
name and the when I think of all the
people who have come and gone and all
the things that they were trying to
accomplish their ambitions bigger petty
whatever mark they made on the world or
didn't make on the world it comes down
to the relationships that we had with
the people who were closest to us and if
we're successful human beings at all
we're alive as long as people remember
our name
when my father died and my father was a
humble man he was a construction worker
the church was standing room only mm-hmm
Wow the and then everyone went over to
the graveside yeah and you know I've
been to fair number of funerals in my
day and there's something poignant and
sad when there's like three people who
show up totally right and there were so
many people who showed up that he had
touched their lives and I'm his oldest
daughter and I had no idea
Wow right it's like wait what I've never
heard this story why didn't I get to
those stories why didn't you know and
and it's interesting because we never
really know our parents Yeah Yeah right
we think it's like a mom dad whatever
and they're sitting there on the couch
reading the newspaper in order to get
behind their eyes and ask good questions
that query their most profound
experiences or even to be able to
recognize them as whole people and not
just a stereotypical role very narrow
very flat two-dimensional right and you
want to have the biggest funeral ever
the most people show up to your funeral
ever because I know and it was just
crazy because my sister's never looking
around like okay we recognize a lot of
these people but who are these other
people and and he was just a
construction worker but what his gift
was was attention and he was very wise
and he mentored a lot of young people
yeah in his life and those people came
back yeah
and showed up to thank him because he
listened and he was interested and he
was curious yeah
you know and I'm like wow this is a
beautiful story about your department
and and everybody was there and it was
amazing it was amazing I should be so
lucky that I have do you know I was
thinking when I die will will you know
hopefully my son will show up and you
know there might be four people but I
could not in my lot in my imagination
envision having so many people show up
at my own funeral yeah yeah that's same
what a cool goal I love that goal of
causing so much love cascades of love
ripples that forever
land in people's hearts so important
yeah yeah and so that becomes part of
their epigenetic memory yeah right you
know we talked about genetics and
epigenetics and people inherit their
ancestors memories yeah in elderly yeah
can we can we push this kindness as far
into the future as possible and what
might that look like yeah you know you
know you know in Ronnie Edgar who did
Israel loves around he did this
illustration of a heart and and he says
this is a bomb throw it hmm right and so
imagine throwing love love bombs love
bombs for generations into the future
yeah kindness bombs free Jenner and and
that in in what I mean is that it's it's
in people's cells it's in their DNA you
rewritten their DNA DNA in a way that
future generations will thrive we're
really good at rewriting people's
epigenetics so that people have
inherited trauma yeah what might it look
like if we could rewrite people's
genetics so that they had inherited
kindness yeah yeah
love it I love it I love I love how it's
both talking about the way to to cause
these cascades these ripples of landing
kindness in people's hearts but it's
also the action of it of actually
implementing that is through the
positive pro-social behavior change and
then pairing those things together is a
recipe for beautiful future yeah
especially working in you know behavior
change this is an interesting question
to ask you what are your thoughts on
free will versus determinism ah my
goodness as a Catholic girl I remember
he's going back and forth on this
I think it's an ant I don't think it's
an or mm-hmm because again context
shapes the the potentiality of what
behaviors are possible right and so you
you you change a person's context it
changes how they'll behave so if I'm in
a very restricted environment that I
only have one choice there's no free
will if I have millions of degrees of
freedom to do something then I've got a
lot of for you I have a lot because free
will is really about agency right and
and and free will and if we think about
agency and I've been in Silicon Valley a
long time and I didn't come from a
privileged background but I have lived
and worked among people who have had
great privilege and grew up with great
privilege the mindset of people who have
privilege is that they have free will
okay the minds of people who have not
grown with privilege is they don't feel
they have free will mm-hmm
and both are true because if you grew up
in poverty if you grow up in limited
circumstances there's just not you don't
have a lot of your locus of control is
incredibly small right you have a dollar
for that meal and that's all you have
versus abundance I can buy whatever I
want exactly exactly so I think both
exist in the world part of my work is to
help people get more agency and part of
getting more agency is being very clear
on what you want mm-hmm I grew up in a
context where I didn't want anything
because it wasn't possible so my I want
muscle is about as good as my bicep
disease days it's pretty there's not
much there but other people who grow up
with their I want where their parents
are asking Johnny so what do you want
they're constantly thinking about what
they want and then more often not than
not they get it and so they you know
they got a big bicep on that part of it
for me is like how do I get that mental
fitness to start exercising your I want
because when you do that then you start
imagining the world that you want the
life that you want how you want your day
to be
and it can be as little a smaller choice
as you know do you want milk in your
coffee or do you want soy milk in your
coffee do you want chocolate or vanilla
do you want to drive this route or that
route
right all those things are small acts of
will of agency and when we start being
intentional about that then we start
being intentional about how do we design
our life and when we start curating and
designing our life it affects the people
around us and that and they behave
differently because you're different and
it there's a ripple effect mm-hmm okay
and then do you think that this is a
simulation
it doesn't matter why our brains can't
tell the difference
it doesn't matter
okay and what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world the most
beautiful thing in the world
nature life
life in all its glory
yeah
such a blessing to have endeavored into
life yeah yeah
if you've ever made life you go oh my
god I made life I made life this baby
came out of me I grew up that or I grew
food too is good I grew life in that
Center when I was pregnant it was a very
interesting experience because prior to
that was basically a brain on a stick I
wasn't really connected to my body all
that much and then I got pregnant mm-hmm
and my body kicked my brain to the curb
and said move over sister we're in
charge now and it was the strangest
feeling I've ever had in my entire life
did you become like super more connected
to your system too absolutely what
you're eating is what the baby's eating
right but it wasn't it wasn't
intellectual pregnancy he's not a head
exercise it was all it's it's it's it's
it's your heart and your body and
everything else same like we got this we
were built to do this you just get out
of the way men need to somehow feel that
if men can feel that we can have a
better world and if yeah that's a yeah
because then you realize oh I am really
super responsible everything I do is
going to impact that person and so when
we think about how good we can be to
each other that is about as elementals
you can be because you have these cells
growing inside your body in the process
of becoming yeah and what you eat and
what you think and what you feel and
your stress and and your emotional state
and your mental state and everything all
have an influence on that other person
so you can either inflict violence on
that person that they will carry for the
rest of their lives
or you can inflict love and kindness on
that person that will influence them for
the rest of their lives it's your choice
yeah yeah so that's that's about as
close to being God as I've ever been
oh okay thank you so much for coming on
our show you're welcome thank you thank
you for all your incredible work yeah
thank you
it's such an honor and a pleasure to
collaborate with peace Innovation Lab
and and just hopefully catalyze more
positive pro-social behavior around the
world and have all these examples that
you've got to unpack for us on the
program and hopefully inspire other
people you guys have to yeah to take
action yes yes thank you and everyone
and check out all the links in the bio
below to margaritas work you can check
that out on her website margarita Kiwis
calm also a peace innovation
stanford.edu and peace innovation calm
as well check those out check out her
LinkedIn and Twitter profiles check out
the peace innovation Twitter as well
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about peace innovation in general
about values based innovation about
positive pro-social behavior about how
we can incentivize that and spread that
around the world everyone and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders in your communities that you
believe in support them and help them
grow you can find all of our links below
to simulation you can help us continue
doing cool things like collaborating
with great organizations like the peace
Innovation Lab and also go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace